-Chrissy, you and I --
-Oh, my gosh.
-You and I were talking
a few days ago
about your appearance tonight,
and I said, "You know,
we could talk about your
cookbook, about having a kid,
all that type of stuff."
-Uh-huh.
-And then as a joke,
I started asking you some
very personal questions
that I would never be able
to ask you on TV.
But then I said,
"Is there a world
where you could
even answer these?"
And you had
a great comeback line.
Do you remember what you said?
-Yes.
I said,
"I will tell you the answers
as long as people
don't know the question."
-And that is genius.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-So I said, "Okay, that works."
Which brings us to a new game.
This is "Loaded Questions."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Loaded, Loaded,
Loaded Questions, yeah ♪
-Here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns
choosing a shot.
Each shot sits on a coaster
which has a personal question
written on it.
Neither of us have seen
these questions before.
You will read
the question silently,
but you will give
your answer out loud.
-Okay.
-And then you will have to
choose whether to share
what the question was
or you can take the shot
and keep it a secret.
-Trembling.
-Okay? All right.
-Okay.
-Tonight, America is finally
going to get all the answers,
just not all the questions.
-This is good.
This is really good.
-All right. Let's play this.
All right. Here we go.
Chrissy, you go first.
That's yours.
-Okay.
-You don't have to do the shot.
Just move it off the coaster
and flip it over.
Well, it actually has
the name of the shot,
as well, on the top.
-Oh, this is called
Satan's Testicles.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't get to know what kind
of alcohol is in there?
-No. No.
-Okay.
-You find out after
the allergic reaction starts.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-What is the answer?
-Um...
-Come on.
You're just saying the answer.
It's no big deal. We don't
even know what the question is.
[ Laughter ]
-Rob Kardashian.
[ Audience oohs ]
-What?!
What are you talking about,
Rob Kardashian?
What does that mean?
-So, now, I don't want you
to know the question.
So I have to drink it?
-Yeah.
Yeah, or you can let us know
what the question is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?! You can't just say
"Rob Kardashian."
Really?
-Woman: Tell us!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No. I'm good.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now I don't know.
Rob Kardashian. All right.
-This is delicious,
first of all.
I don't know if I'm
gonna answer anything.
This is amazing.
-All right, I also...
-Okay, your turn. Your turn.
...have the Devil's Testicles.
Sorry. Satan's Testicles.
-Devil...
[ Laughter ]
-I don't have
the devil's testicles.
-You just said you did.
-No, no, I know I said I did.
-You said you did.
-But I meant the drink.
-I know. I know.
[ Laughter ]
Don't you --
That's not even the question.
All right. Here we go.
-Okay.
-Ooh, okay, all right. Oh.
Uh...$6,000.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Yeah.
-Bloop!
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No.
-I can't look at it?
-No, you can't look at it.
-No. That's my secret.
-But they won't know.
But it's me. Okay.
-Just know it's $6,000.
-Oh, man, I want to know
what that one is so bad.
-Nuh-unh-unh.
-"This is plain old poison."
-Well, that's the name
of the shot. Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Wow. That's a good shot.
-Is this, like,
in a year or a week?
Can I ask -- Can I say that?
-I don't know
what the question is.
[ Laughter ]
You're reading it.
-I'm happy with
three times a week.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Now, I think I know what --
[ Laughs ]
I think I know
what the question could be,
but, also, it could be
something else.
You're happy with
three times a week.
-Mm-hmm.
-Is John happy with
three times...?
-I didn't say
anything about John!
I didn't say anything!
-I didn't say anything, either.
I'm just saying --
-It could be anything, Jimmy.
-It could be anything. I know.
Could be anything.
-It could be anything.
-It also could be
something else.
[ Laughter ]
What are you choosing?
Oh, my gosh.
This game is cruel, man.
-Ohh.
-This game is cruel.
-Can we burn this?
I feel -- I'm so scared.
Okay.
-Here. I'll take it.
-Okay. Oh, no! Jimmy, no!
Oh, my God. I would die.
I would die.
-This really is crazy. All
right. All right. Here we go.
All right. Uh...
Okay. Never.
It's not the same question
as your question.
[ Laughter ]
No. That's --
I have different questions.
My wife is very --
I love her very much.
She's very -- No. That's not --
That's not the question.
Uh, I'll tell you the question.
"How often do you
Google yourself?"
-Oh.
-Never.
-Do you Google yourself?
-Not for a long time.
-Right?
-Only when I say something dumb,
and I'm like,
"Oh, are people mad?"
-Dude, that happens every night
for me, so I just don't do it.
Okay. You're up,
and this shot looks crazy.
I want to know what it's called.
-Yeah, this -- this looks risky.
[ Clears throat ]
-Smells cinnamony.
-Ooh.
-Well, it's...
-Fireball?
-...Twitter Troll Sweat.
Twitter Troll Sweat.
-Twitter Troll Sweat.
♪♪
Look at your --
Look at your head thinking now.
This must be a good
personal question.
♪♪
What's going on?
What?
♪♪
What's happening?
-I'm taking this very serious.
♪♪
-What is going on right now?
-We also have to
burn this one, I think.
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Wait. What?!
You have to tell me
what the question was!
-No!
-What is the question?
You have to tell me what
the question was. It's me?
♪♪
I just want to --
I'm gonna take this off.
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're insane.
You'll take it to the grave?
Oh, my God. You're...
[ Tuba plays fog horn ]
-You'll never know that.
[ Air horn blares ]
No one will ever know
the answer to that one.
-Uh-oh. Does that mean --
That's our final round.
Let's bring in the shots
right here.
Okay, this is --
-I have to --
I still have to be a guest.
-I know, but these
are Jell-O shots.
Okay, here's the way this is.
The shot board just rolled in.
We're both going to do
the same question for this one.
This shot is called...
-If any of your writers tell you
what the question was, I'll die.
-They'll never tell me.
-Yeah, I bet. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
-You can tell me, though.
-No.
[ Laughs ]
I can't believe this, man.
-This is such a good game,
but, like, I want to watch it.
I don't want to be
on it anymore. Okay.
-This shot is called
Jell-O From The Other Side.
Oh, I get it. I get it.
-♪ Jell-O from the other side ♪
-Okay. All right.
This is the question.
[ Drum roll ]
-Same time?
-Yep.
One, two, three.
-Gentlemen's club.
-A hotel in Nashville.
[ Laughter ]
Wow! Really, though?
-Really?
-Gentlemen's club?
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Do you want to do the shot
or tell everyone the question?
[ Audience shouting ]
Question.
-We'll do the question.
-"What's the weirdest place
you've ever woken up?"
Gentlemen's club?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Wow.
I want to know that story.
I only said Nashville,
a hotel in Nashville
because it started in New York.
I'm serious. Yeah.
You got to stay away from these.
-That sounds equally as awesome.
Are we still just...?
-Cheers.
We're going to do it anyway.
Chrissy Teigen, everybody.
More with Chrissy after
the break. Stick around.
♪♪